now is it true that you guys are on an
snl lady uh text chain is this true we
do chat with one another a lot okay
what is it like to be on that text chain
it's great because we we we've
there's laughs and advice and a lot of
common experience which i think is sort
of it's a weird sorority that we're in
so it's nice to sort of have that
shared experience um
stay relevant and in our grown-up lives
can i ask like i mean this morning chris
miller my partner of 20 years he was
filming in the hallway to get to your
name plaque and talk about debbie downer
you know i mean it's like what is your
favorite character and memory for both
of you from snl i had another thought
when you said that when you're talking
about debbie downer it is amazing like i
i was watching a movie with my son that
was filmed in australia like i don't
know three or four years ago and out of
the blue in the movie in australia
this little like little known film the
guy goes okay db dana about somebody and
it was like to know this person that
created this character that saturated
culture so much that an australian film
would have like a you know casual
reference to db dana
it's wild that it's the same person or
like we talk about like tina and mom
jeans or like these sort of vernacular
moments that are part of our bigger
culture
how did you come up with it's not a
hilarious story
well i was i was on a trip and somebody
like that i didn't know like there was a
chit chat happening and someone asked a
really downer question and then i sort
of filed it away and then then it just
popped into my head and then i wrote it
with paula pell yeah and um he was
amazing and first we were trying to
write we said it in an office it just
wasn't really flowing and then we're
like wait we have to put this like
somewhere really really happy so we said
it at disney world
and anna what is your favorite character
and memory from snl it's i don't i guess
i guess i'll be the music teachers with
with will i think just in terms of like
again i didn't know if you're going to
say like you and molly into it
very close very close contest between
npr in terms of just i like working and
i like collaborating and working with
other people but i would say the we the
music teachers just like in terms of the
inside lore of snl like we would start
that sketch at earliest at 6 a.m on
wednesday morning and it was just like
finals week in high school you know like
just or in college where it was just
like we got to we should start but wait
let me just tell you one more thing oh
my gosh
me and power and makeup yeah everyone
every morning so we we would laugh until
we were like blue in the face about not
things relevant to the to the sketch and
then we would write the sketch not that
hard and then performing it was always
fun too thank you for what you'd both do
you guys serious absolutely
i love that um all right you have to get
to this story because it's my favorite
one of the day well here uh i'm obsessed
with this you know it's up up and away
on love cloud i'll explain the new york
times reports that's the name of a new
private flight service that lets you
officially join the mile high club yup
for the low price of 90.
995 you get 45 minutes in the air with a
twin mattress covered in satin sheets
and then when the deed is done you just
walk away with an official mile high
club certificate
signed by the pilot who by the way
will just be in the cockpit
the whole time with a curtain wearing
noise canceling headphones can you guys
believe what are your thoughts
immediately obviously yeah rachel i
picture like maybe
maybe like 80 of these is some guy like
look what i got for us and the woman's
like oh i thought we were going
somewhere fun
like i thought they were going on a
vacation and then like no you're just
going up in the sky i'm sorry quickly
some nasty silk sheets
no i don't know what do you think am i
being a prude here no well you get 45
minutes in the air but i wonder what you
do with the last 41 minutes
[Music]